so Charlie who somehow was the  healthiest of all of us according to Dr  Kipper and you know I've got beef with  that too but we can get to that later  um you know got hit with covid uh pretty  hard I think I was pretty worn down from  that tour that we did when I got it  let's admit it we pushed the liver and  uh did we just prove then Rob's theory  that whiskey kills coven well I didn't  have any at my cousin's wedding which is  I'm pretty sure is where I got it but I  think it was like my aunt's friends  being like yeah it's good to see you  Charlie it's like screaming right into  my mouth like excuse me Charlie I've  been sick for a long time but  you know  yeah it's always good yeah yeah let me  if you don't think that Philly accent  sounds like [ __ ] Rick some kind of  ridiculous Victorian England accent  [Music]